here are the top three most viewed
videos on my YouTube channel but which
one do you think resulted in the most
new subscribers The Answer may surprise
you this Hogwarts Legacy preview video
is my most viewed video to date with
more than 2.5 million views another
Hogwarts Legacy video about the dark
arts has just over a million views and
then there's this Animal Crossing New
Horizons video that hasn't quite cracked
a million yet with 961 000 views as for
new subscribers gained the video viewed
more than 2.5 million times resulted in
3 800 new subscribers the video viewed
one million times resulted in only 995
new subscribers but the animal crossing
video with 961 thousand views translated
to 5 200 new subscribers